My father has always been
my greatest champion
and my hero.
Congratulations on 50 years
at the top of the biz.
I love you, Dad.
That was perfect.
You wanna try one more?
If it was perfect,
why would I want one more?
Why don't we just do one more
where...
maybe you really, like,
sell how-- how you're feeling.
-Yeah, okay, let's do it.
-All right, take four.
What up, prick-licks?
It's me, Doctor Moron!
I'm a ding-dong,
doodlebug dipshit,
and my dad hates all of you.
How was that, was that good?
LOGAN ROY:
We could fight this takeover.
We keep close,
in the whole family.
I swear to God, Dad,
if you bring him back,
I am walking.
Back to my office, to sulk.
-Ow!
-We're going for PGM.
-Pierce... good?
-Yeah, let's do it. I like it.
Oh, don't be such a suck-up,
it's pathetic.
What about you, Romulus?
I fucking love it,
but that's my honest opinion.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Son, business is a competition.
I land the deal, I kill Kendall,
I'm crowned the king.
Just like in Hamlet. If that
happens in Hamlet, I don't care.
The thing I keep turning over
in my mind is, do I tell Dad?
Because if I drop the shoe
on Ken now,
-he's crushed forever.
-If Kendall's going rogue,
then let him.
Sooner or later, it's going to
blow up in his face.
-I love it when it blows up
in people's faces.
-SHIV ROY: You do.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
(EXPLOSION)
-ROMAN ROY: How many died?
-GERRI: Two guys lost thumbs,
and there might be an arm
they can't save.
Guess who just didn't kill
anyone, but maybe only lost
a couple of thumbs.
-I-- I don't know.
-This guy!
-How are you?
-Uh, you know, I'm well.
I'm very well. I'm, uh,
workin' real hard, you know?
-Yeah?
-Yeah. No, uh, not at all,
-really, maybe, who knows?
-Wow.
I don't have the attention span.
Like this is probably
the most interesting thing
that's happened in my whole life
and I'm thinking about, like,
six other things.
Can I suggest
we all take our shirts off?
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Should we... get married?
-What?
-You know, not that, like, uh,
an equivalent, uh, the thing.
Like I abduct you and force you
to live with me.
-Uh-- That's not equivalent.
-Anyway, it's a lot to think
about, I get it, so let it...
Bye.
I have this overwhelming urge
to either knee someone
in the vagina,
or spit on the floor.
I suck at the whole corporate
flirt thing.
Metro-poser bullshit...
Beehives, almond milk...
Napkins and chit-chat!
Take another week
on that report, Matilda.
I've always thought of you,
and I mean this in the best
possible way,
as a stone-cold, killer bitch.
Who says you don't know
how to flirt?
You guys are a team, and, uh,
when a team is a team,
they can't actually physically
be beaten. It's impossible.
So, go hard, go fast,
go, you lovely bastards.
Roman, you're a moron.
-ROMAN: I am not a moron.
-I think you're a super-talented
superstar, and I-- I love you.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
Oh, you're such a fucking bitch.
You know how you're so efficient
and good at your job?
-Well, thank you.
-And you're also sort of, like,
invisible, like wallpaper.
Like a boring, old,
sort of nothing.
Like a competent, kind of
clever filing cabinet
that everyone seems content
to have around.
Oh, I'm sorry,
am I interrupting something?
Would you like to give this man
your number?
Yeah, I'd like to give him
my number.
Why don't you ask
for her number then?
Can I get your number?
(CHUCKLING)
Can I get a pen please?
Mmm. Wait, wait, wait! Ba-- Ba--
(WINE POURING)
And fetch another bottle,
please. Thank you.
No amount of antibacterial gel
is going to be able to wipe
the America off me.
-What do everyday people like?
-What do you like?
-Me?
-Yeah.
Okay, uh, I enjoy spending time
with my nephews,
Cooper and Clarke.
-I hike. I have several
high-end racing drones--
-Oh, my God, stop.
No offense, but wow.
-Roman, good morning.
-Uh, no, uh, correction,
it is not a good morning
from my POV,
because you're here
and I fucking hate you.
Hey, nice vest, Wambsgans.
It's so puffy.
-Thank you, Roman.
-What's it stuffed with,
your hopes and dreams?
Are you kidding about
the presidential thing?
No, I'm still applying
for the job of President
of the United States.
-Oh, good for you!
-Yeah, do you think that
that's like
a natural progression
from never done nothing, never,
to the most important job
in the world?
-Well--
-Like, could you maybe get
a little experience
at, like, a CVS?
-Dad fired you, man.
-No, he said it was just
gonna take a little longer.
But he said that to be nice.
What I think he meant to say
was that he wished that Mom
gave birth to a can opener,
because at least then
it would be useful.
-Two drinks maximum.
-ROMAN: That's okay. Nobody here
has any glaring substance abuse
issues that almost brought down
the company, right?
-ROMAN: You got a haircut.
-Yeah.
ROMAN: I hate it.
-Ro--
-Yeah.
...you wanna get a booster seat
for you when you're out there?
-That's hilarious.
Your period just came on.
-Guys...
Are your nips hard?
They must be, because you
are so out in the cold.
(GROANS)
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
I'm thinkin', I throw three
or four dozen
white-shoe lawyers
at you and see what it'd be like
to actually physically destroy
someone.
Dude,
I don't know what happened,
but I'm sure I can fix it.
Mm-hmm.
(LAUGHS) Fuck you.
-Oh, Jesus, look at you!
Look at your face!
-Oh, fuck you, dude!
-You're a piece of shit.
-Yeah! (CHUCKLES)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
-(ELEVATOR DINGS)
-ROMAN: Oh!
-Please.
-After you, milady.
Nope, chivalry is not,
you know... (MUMBLES)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪